Blake Shelton and Gwen Stefani are
stronger than ever now a source tells ET
they want to have a baby a source close
to the 41 year old country singer tells
ET that the two are making plans for the
future
quote they are very committed to one
another and this is a forever thing
however more important to them right now
is having a baby together the source
adds that Shelton has baby fever quote
when we love nothing more than to give
Blake his first child
Blake is dying to be a father he loves
Gwen's kids which has made him realize
he could be a good father ET caught up
with Shelton in September and he
admitted that working on The Voice
sparked his paternal instinct I never
thought in a million years when I signed
on to do that show that I would ever be
so like defensive and and actively
defensive you know when it comes to you
know reading a you know a blog or a
critique about one of my artists you
know the first season or two men I
couldn't help but I would just lose my
mind when I would see somebody picking
on a kid you know Shelton also opened up
about his recent trip to Oklahoma with
Stefani and her whole family for the
grand opening of his new restaurant old
red it's been a lot of fun for me too to
be the one to get to expose them to this
out in the country basically you know
and they said they loved it so much her
entire family now and I say her family I
mean all I'm talking about the kids the
the mom the dad the brother you know
it's just you know there's times when
we've had like holiday gatherings and
I'm talking about 30 plus family members
from from her side from my side and the
voice coach revealed that the families
get along great we have so much fun I
don't think you should be able to have
that much fun it's probably not legal in
California
[Music]
you